bonjour nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'actu
sur tv fil 78 nous allons faire le tour
de l'actualité du département voici les
principaux titres de ce 27 septembre
départ de la majorité du premier adjoint
udi tensions autour des investitures ps
et ump pour les municipales
multiplication des candidatures
le dernier conseil municipal vient de se
tenir à maurepas et il était pour le
moins agité 3 contrat d'avenir signé ce
matin la verrière par le ministre de la
ville et le ministre de l'économie
solidaire l'occasion également de
revenir sur l'ouverture aux emplois
flanc de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
et puis le groupe monastère amer fait le
buzz avec plus de 60000 vu en quelques
jours sur internet ceux de son clip hip
hop versailles de versailles mathias et
hugo savary
nous présenterons ce rap royalistes on
commence par l'image de ce vendredi
l'image de cette édition 1ère séance de
rentrée au conseil général des yvelines
beaucoup de monde en coulisse
certainement impatients et curieux de
revoir si j'ai l'ancien président du
conseil général pierre bédier
pendant toute la séance le conseiller
général de man tu n'as pas pris part aux
débats assez concentré mais très
silencieux permet d'y et va intégrer la
commission permanente et la deuxième
commission équipement tout juste at il
souri quand le président alain schmitz
en en parlant de l'importance des enjeux
de paris métropole a salué son retour
par ces mots son expérience sans pareil
nous sera utile ans se souvient et qu'il
y a quelques mois on murmurait dans les
allées du conseil général que pierre
bédier aurait aimé retrouver le fauteuil
de président aujourd'hui les élus ump
affiche un fonds commun on a besoin d'un
linge de d'alain schmitz aussi donc
c'est ça l'amitié ce n'est pas une
amitié de trente ans mais c'est une
amitié forte qu alain schmitz est mon
ami donc après ne partait pas sur des
considérations politiques
ça vous obsède cette présidence du
conseil général ça vous obsède beaucoup
plus que moi
moi je veux servir
chère madame peu importe les postes
l'important c'est de servir l'important
c'est d'avoir des idées et l'important
c'est d'avoir la capacité de mettre en
oeuvre ses idées pour justement servir
les populations
voilà j'entends mes collègues de la
majorité dire on a besoin de pierre
bédier contenu de ces grandes
difficultés que connaît le département
on a vu ce matin qu'en fait tout ça est
très artificielle
département continue il va continuer
c'est un non événement
ça fait beaucoup de vagues à l'intérieur
de la majorité départementale pour moi
personnellement c'est un non événement
et qui sera le prochain maire de
maurepas ce pourrait être le nom d'une
émission télé mais il y aura en tout cas
beaucoup de suspense au cours des
prochains mois dans cette commune cet
homme entendent à s'installer sur le
fauteuil de premier magistrat détenue
depuis et quatre mandats par l'ancien
socialiste georges mougeot et hier soir
jeudi lors d'un conseil municipal somme
toute assez ordinaire chacun a commencé
à dévoiler ses cartes
qui sera le prochain maire de maurepas 7
ils sont aujourd'hui 7 à convoiter le
poste occupé par georges mougeot depuis
quatre mandats et ils se sont retrouvés
jeudi soir lors du conseil municipal
michel chapa deuxième adjoint aux
finances divers gauche soutenu
officiellement par le maire sortant
michel est également adjoint au sport
celui ci et qui se présentera sur une
liste indépendante associative
hervé miclo adjoint socialiste à la
culture qui sollicitent l'investiture
d'ailleurs de sa formation
tout comme ismaïl à vannes conseiller
général ps du canton de maurepas sans
oublier jean sindou faurie dans
l'opposition écologiste pierre
leguérinel premier adjoint de la
majorité représentant de l'udps et qui
sollicite le soutien de l'ump ainsi que
grégory gare et astier qui siégeait pour
la première fois en remplacement d'un
conseiller d'opposition démissionnaire
lui aussi envisage l'investiture de
l'ump en mars
en tant que chef de file du parti sur
cette ville et entre les deux hommes le
ton se durcit et je rappelle quand même
que monsieur lionel était investi par le
ps en 2008 et que maintenant il essaye
de repartir à droite un coup à gauche un
coup à droite
moi j'appelle ça un obtenir un objet
politique non identifié on ne sait pas
trop ce qui veut faire on ne sait pas
trop où il est donc qu'il règle ses
problèmes avec lui dit il n'aura pas
fallu attendre longtemps pour que la
tension monte encore d'un cran en salle
du conseil
après l'annonce par pierre leguérinel de
sa démission de la majorité afin de
préparer sa campagne son opposant n'a
pas fait dans la demi-mesure en parlant
de mascarade
il a été en réalité désigné comme tête
de file même s'il a dit longtemps qu'il
était investi je crois qu'il ya eu un
rappel à l'ordre de la part de la
présidente de la fédération pour dire
que ça n'était pas ça c'est parfaitement
clair monsieur gressier n'est pas
l'investiture
vous voulez un scoop et bien j'aurai
comme colistière n'a numéro 2 de glee
sera
celle qui la dernière fois avait monté
une liste à côté de la mienne
ce sera nicole malacca et l'ump devrait
trancher avant la fin de l'année et
choisir son représentant en mars
du côté des socialistes la scène a été
observé avec attention par ismaila
vannes et harvey milk l'eau eux aussi en
concurrence donc et qui attendent que
les militants fassent leur choix le 10
octobre toute ambition est légitime
je le dis comme je lui ai dit comme la
section le sait je pense qu'il ya un
poste de conseiller général à assumer
qu'il faut le reprendre en 2015 mais je
pense qu'une complémentarité est plus
significatif que le ps qu'il concurrence
interne une fois les investitures
officialisé de part et d'autre restera
ensuite aux candidats à composer avec
les listes indépendantes mais aussi
dissidente michel chapa élu depuis 1989
le seul à avoir reçu le soutien officiel
du maire se dit serein il y en a qui
choisissent une politique de rupture un
programme de rupture ils le disent ben
moi ça sera tout le contraire ça sera
une politique de continuité un programme
de continuité bien entendu qui évoluera
qui présentera des propositions
nouvelles
quand on décide de se présenter c'est
qu'il ya autour de soi un certain nombre
de personnes qui vont dans le même sens
ce qui pousse en général qui pousse qui
acceptent qu'ils coopèrent qui sont en
plein accord avec soi-même on n'y va pas
comme ça tout seul alors effectivement
il ya une équipe assez fourni autour de
moi prête à assumer les responsabilités
politiques toujours et autres tensions
les maires de plaisir et de villepreux
ont réaffirmé lors d'une conférence de
presse commune leur intention de
constituer une intercommunalité avec la
ville des clayes-sous-bois comme la loi
les y oblige
avant le 1er janvier 2014 une conférence
de presse qui s'est tenue tout juste une
semaine après celle de véronique côté
millard la mer des clayes-sous-bois qui
elles remettent en cause ce mariage un
mariage à deux ce n'est parfois pas
simple alors à trois quand il s'agit
d'intercommunalité les choses peuvent se
corser il y a une semaine véronique côté
millard à la mer des quais sous bois
disait non à l'intercommunalité entre sa
commune et celle de plaisir et de
villepreux au motif que cela va coûter
cher à mettre en place et qu'elle est
trop petit en nombre d'habitants
ce lundi les deux mère joséphine
berger stéphane mirambeau
tenait une conférence de presse commune
pour réaffirmer
nécessité de cette union vraiment aller
dans ce sens de la mutualisation pas du
tout de la débauche financière bien au
contraire plutôt de l'économie et puis
d'une rationalisation et d'un apport
même supplémentaires par rapport aux
attentes des plaisirs va ça me paraît
fondamental cette démarche et je pense
que c'est un terreau cours va nous
permettre de faire des choses qu'on
n'aurait peut-être pas pu faire tout
seul quand on voit les trois villes moi
je parlais de vie des produits les
clayes-sous-bois on a tellement de
choses en commun que c'est une évidence
on n'arrive même plus à voir si on est
dans l'une des villes où l'autre on a
dit c'est comme un la guerre commune
nous avons les pompiers donc ça tout ça
tout son sens d'être ensemble
véronique côté millard souhaite saisir
un avocat pour faire invalider la
décision préfectorale
les maires tendent la main à leurs
voisines je crois qu'il faut se préparer
et avant de rentrer dans une opération
de grande envergure il vaut mieux se
préparer sur quelque chose
d'intermédiaire
donc j'essaye de lui pas de lui faire
comprendre parce qu'elle ne comprend
très très bien mais j'essaie de la
convaincre et avec monsieur mirambeau
mais vraiment dans cette dynamique la
machine presque convaincu qu'elle
viendra en tout cas assister aux
réunions
la première priorité c'est les statuts
donc il va y avoir des réunions pour sa
voix dans cette intercommunalité les
compétences qu'on transfère et il faut
absolument
c'est dans ce cadre là que la mère des
classes ou basse avec nous sinon nous
pouvons décider aujourd'hui et si c'est
cela à deux mais ça n'a pas de sens
les trois communes doivent donc présenté
leur projet d'ici la fin de l'année deux
à trois réunions sont déjà programmées
de 7 à 10% la tva pour les loisirs de
plein air va fortement augmenter en
janvier comme les parcs de loisirs les
parcs zoologiques font partie de cette
catégorie et à thoiry on s'inquiète des
conséquences pour les salariés mais
aussi pour les visiteurs sur le prix
d'entrée et sur le prix du billet l'on
ne comprend pas surtout pourquoi il
n'existe pas de dérogation en raison de
leur mission de préservation de la
nature et demande de lapanouse le
président du parc et du château de
thoiry a adressé une lettre ouverte au
ministre des finances il rappelle que la
précédente augmentation de 5 5 à 7% lui
a déjà coûté très cher le fait
d'augmenter le taux de tva à 7 déjà ça a
causé un premier pas ça coûte combien
parce qu'on a presque déjà un milliard
ça coûtait 150 mille euros inc c'est
rien c'est pour les dernières 5 500 2 on
a perdu 150 millions euros par an et les
premiers coups ont été pénalisés en
histoire c'est d'abord l'état sur
l'impôt sur les bénéfices parce qu' on a
eu moins suivi de l'intéressement la
participation pour les salariés aussi et
ensuite les animaux parce que ça nous a
fait on a eu moins d'argent pour
investir dans des négociations
animalière quand on prend un point à un
point et demi de tva on perd 150 mille
saveurs comprenait trois points vous
allez perdre 300 milles exactement
benoît hamon ministre en charge de
l'économie solidaire françois lamy
ministre délégué à la ville ont fait le
déplacement ce vendredi à trappes à la
verrière ils ont signé plus précisément
une convention d'objectifs pour le
développement et l'entrepreneuriat
social dans les quartiers populaires
parmi les mesures des heures de travail
sur le marché des rénovations urbaines
seront réservés à des jeunes issus de
ces quartiers les ministres sont aussi
revenu sur le récent dispositif des
emplois francs lancé en juillet dernier
saint quentin en yvelines fait partie
des quarante sites concernés on écoute
le ministre de la ville à la verrière
donc au micro de yolaine 13 et de clerck
en biais donc je sais de
nous permettre de mettre plus de moyens
à l'intérieur de ces quartiers avec le
fait qu'on n'aura plus de conseillers de
pôle emploi dans les zones urbaines
sensibles que on va développer un
nouveau dispositif qui est celui des
emplois franck-yves à un dispositif
qu'ils étaient donne une chance
supplémentaire un jeune tout
particulièrement diplômés j'ai souvent
stigmatisés à cause de son adresse voilà
est en cours en ville pionnière dans le
domaine des nouvelles technologies à
l'école a reçu la visite du recteur de
l'académie de versailles tablette à
l'école tableau numérique et maintenant
robot humanoïde c'est la dernière
innovation en date
yolaine thorez elodie moines ont fait la
connaissance de ce robot nous voici à
l'école numérique d'elancourt des robots
appelés now viennent de faire leur
entrée et peuvent raconter des histoires
qui se passait ici on a franchi le pas
de l'ère numérique depuis dix ans déjà
aujourd'hui la ville va encore plus loin
avec ce tout nouveau robot objectif
développer le goût des sciences de
l'ingénieur chez les enfants les enfants
vont le programme et est donc dès que
vous faites un travail louis résultats
tout de suite un robot qui changent de
comportement vous imaginez le l'oeil
pour l'apprentissage c'est idéal c'est
très concret et vous développer
l'intelligence logico mathématique
autres innovations de la rentrée 2000
tablettes numériques pour tous les
élèves de l'école élémentaire
chacun y stocke ses propres lectures ses
poésies mais aussi des documents audio
et vidéo
un outil très pratique mais qui ne
remplace pas nos bons vieux cahiers les
enfants doivent continuer à écrire c'est
très important de continuer à écrire
donc c'est un support supplémentaire
ils ne travaillent pas tous au même
rythme ils n'ont pas tous
acquis les compétences tous en même
temps donc moi par exemple je peux
varier choisir les exercices donc là ça
va personnaliser oui mais dans le monde
dans le bon sens à terme les élèves pour
ou même emmener leur tablette à la
maison mais uniquement pour travailler
sur leurs leçons
une semaine de dépistage rapide du vih
se déroule à travers l'île de france 600
acteurs mobilisés sur le terrain
jusqu'au 29 septembre pour aller à la
rencontre de ceux qui n'osent pas se
rendre à l'hôpital afin de vérifier leur
statut sérologique l' agence régionale
de santé et la région ile de france
également sont à l'origine de cet
événement on écoute leurs présidents
respectifs c'était à paris lors du
lancement de cet événement
l'alf l'acheter c'est d'aller au plus
proche des gens et notamment des
populations vulnérables pour leur
permettre de se faire dépister d'avoir
des informations et de les rapprocher du
système de santé
on sait qu'ils aient un certain nombre
de gens qui ont beaucoup de mal à
approcher le système de santé pour des
raisons qui sont parfois difficiles à
comprendre
aujourd'hui il faut leur montrer que
savoir c'est mieux que de ne pas savoir
et que vous savez moi j'ai appris ma
séropositivité il ya 25 ans il y avait
pas de traitement
je comprends qu'à ce moment là les gens
avaient peur parce que quelque part
c'était comme un arrêt de mort
aujourd'hui on sait qu'on peut vivre et
survivre avec le sida même si ça reste
une maladie mortelle et donc il faut que
ces populations comprennent que chacun
comprenne qui vaut mieux savoir que de
pas savoir
au delà de cette semaine de
sensibilisation il est possible d'avoir
accès à ce test de dépistage rapide
auprès d'associations qui ont été
agréées qui ont été formés pour pouvoir
faire ces tests et d'autre part pour
pouvoir accompagner donné l'information
à la personne qui serait
identifié comme étant séropositive et
ses associations leurs références sont
plus accessibles sur le site de sida
info service
ici dans la région donc cette semaine
est une semaine de sensibilisation mais
tout au long de l'année
l'accès au test rapide est possible sur
le terrain les acteurs de prévention
sont donc intervenus pour réaliser ces
flashs test retour sur l'opération
saint-quentinoise c'était au centre
commercial de montigny le bretonneux
avec l'association hf prévention bonjour
on propose un test de dépistage rapide
ces anonymes c'est gratuit et la réponse
est immédiate
ça vous intéresse une piqûre sur le
doigt et la réponse est donnée
immédiatement
l'association hf prévention va
directement chercher les gens pour leur
proposer un test de dépistage
on sait le test de trois gouttes de sang
sont prélevées puis mélangée à des
réactifs une minute après la personne
s'est tout de suite si elle est
séropositive ou non comme j'avais déjà
fait mon taf ya six mois je suis pas
d'appréhension je vais faire le test
quand même pour savoir si depuis apple
changement moi je passais ici par hasard
je ne savais pas qu'ils étaient ça me
permet de faire un test plus
régulièrement parce que des fois que j'y
pense mais j'ai pas le temps alors que
l'oeuvre
ça prend une minute synthèse qui est
extrêmement rapide avant cela passage
obligé avec les animateurs de
l'association
il rappelle quelques règles de
prévention et de réduction des risques
dans un centre de dépistage classique
deux personnes sur 1000 ont été
dépistées séropositives depuis le début
de l'année dans le département
hf prévention en se déplaçant sur les
universités les choeurs de citer ou les
centres commerciaux comme ici on a des
pistes et en moyenne presque dix fois
plus on se rend bien compte que le
centre de dépistage anonyme et gratuit
c'est quand il ya une prise de risque
que les gens y vont ils n'y vont pas
forcément spontanément or aujourd'hui
entre 50 et 60 mille personnes qui sont
séropositives mais qu'ils ne connaissent
pas leur statut sérologique
dans le cadre de la semaine flash test
l'association continue son périple
jusqu'à dimanche ce mardi elle sera à
l'étang du cora à saint-germain-en-laye
jusqu'à 21h merci beaucoup mais je vous
en fais ça
désiré n'hésitez pas à tourner le moa à
tous vos amis et tout ça durera de
passer beaucoup à merci et suite à ce
test à saint-quentin-en-yvelines nous
avons reçu cette semaine sur ce plateau
le président de cette association hf
prévention pour faire le point sur les
résultats malheureusement sans surprise
les résultats ne sont pas très
encourageants on a fait 109 dépistage
alors effectivement on a eu deux
positifs donc c'est toujours compliqué
d'annoncer donc dsr positivité mais
effectivement après les personnes sont
mis sous traitement
donc ce qui est quand même important on
sait déjà que les personnes ont été
prises en charge donc ce qui est quand
même primordial et donc c'est des
personnes qui effectivement après on
doive annoncé au ces à leur conjoint
donc c'est jamais facile
souvent on a des personnes qui sont
dépistés et après on a les conjoints qui
viennent nous voir ou qui sont après
midi dans la boucle connaître son statut
sérologique c'est quand même super
important nous on est des créateurs à la
limite d'événements sur ses centres
commerciaux ces universités ou concret
le moment où on n'avait pas prévu de se
faire dépister et beaumont va se faire
dépister
et ça c'est important et est du coup ça
permet vraiment que les gens connaissent
leur statut sérologique très rapidement
parce que sinon effectivement centres de
dépistage il ya effectivement une
semaine d'attenté je rappelle quand même
qu'à l'institut de promotion de la santé
sur rendez-vous vous pouvez appeler hf
prévention sur rendez vous le matin on
peut vous recevoir pour faire un test
rapide et ça c'est toute l'année
on va parler musique à présent dans ce
journal de rap de hip hop plus
précisément faire du répressif du clip
l'a déjà entendu parler du ministère
amer un groupe de sarcelles connu dans
les années 90 pour ses paroles plutôt
engagés plutôt radicale et bien
aujourd'hui en 2013 place au monastère
hammer un groupe versaillais qui lui
aussi est engagé deux frères sont avec
nous sur ce plateau le monastère amer
hugo et matiéres bonsoir à tous les
2èmes citron vert et oxmo cappuccino
pour les surnoms et vous êtes venus en
tenue et artistes exactement
voilà recevront ce soir sur le plateau
monseigneur sais pas trop difficile dans
la rue de se promener avec ce maquillage
match habillés tous les jours comme ça
chez intense passe pas toujours
même ça attire le regard des passants
même à versailles alors vous avez sorti
ce morceau hip hop de versailles
monastère hammer l'idée c'était quoi
c'était de revenir à ce que faisait les
inconnus auteuil neuilly passy à
quelques années bat là la comparaison
est flatteuse maintenant l'idée c'était
vraiment le concept de parler de
versailles et de le faire à la sauce
moderne de d'aborder le sujet en faisant
ça proprement un vrai raf dessus on va
voir le clip dans quelques instants
oui voilà est ce que je voulais dire
c'est que bon il faut rappeler que les
vraies racines du rap en sont à
versailles je veux dire voilà si on
regarde le premier m6 jean de la
fontaine
voilà c'est là que ça a vraiment
commencé molière il faut rendre à
monnières ce qui est ce qu il appartient
par tient un molière
originaire de versailles vous êtes
originaire de viroflay plus précisément
en général quand on parle de ce secteur
là du département on parle plutôt des
groupes de pop que ce soit air ou daft
punk pas trop d'une hip hop c'est vrai
mais il ya aussi des groupes de hip hop
connu à versailles tu étais fait klub
des loosers
voilà c'est dans cette veine là que vous
vous inscriviez justement quand on a
voulu faire la chose différemment je
pense qu'on a abordé de notre façon
hamon a abordé la chose à notre façon et
versailles en général c'est plutôt le
souffre douleur pour les rappeurs
non ça va pas s'arranger a forcément
versailles zugna on a notre équipe et si
nom de la glace dans le valaisan
versailles sont en tout cas on va
regarder justement un extrait de ce clip
hip hop de versailles monastère amer
elle me suis trouvée
oxmo
avec un nuage
in this versailles j'habite à halle
je crois bien que la france ait trop
et le capital
san martin luther mais avec le kin je
rêve qu'un nouveau le roi soleil brille
j'te voir ce rêve se réaliser que le
château de faire ça remplace l'elysée
donc désolé moi je vais pas voter je
parle d'un président mais dans une tour
à la royauté remballe t paris s'il tonne
à la ferme j'habite au versailles iphone
que tu quittes la terre ferme j'ai mis
mon
cause feront le mic et jeta coach je
suis encore
la poste c'est le son qui vient tout
droit du 10e
m6 est bien scellé
où je m'envoie
au septième ciel c'est
et que pavie
j'te décapiter la branche
tous les cas si royal istres
savary
tu ouais ça
mais ça
stéphane bern
reste une bille ce si beau
la nostalgie de la monarchie
à ce qu'il faut pour qu'à nouveau
l'antienne bientôt le retour du roi
histoire de tolkien
aïe versailles représente sur le plateau
et mathias savary vous faites bien on
peut le refaire
ayhan fait bien bien bien d'entraîner
les auteurs de ce morceau ses monastères
hammer ou c'est un buzz du moment on
peut appeler ça comme ça c'est le mot
consacré le buzz 60000 vu depuis une
semaine depuis la mise en ligne sur
internet c'était attendu
pas du tout vous avez fait ça dans quel
objet de quel objectif
c'était pour s'amuser mais j'étais
largué en fait il y avait pas vraiment
d'objectif c'est ça qui est qui et le
message en importe c'est d'une part un
message
c'est très important pour nous de ce
soit communiquée aux gens on communique
habituellement par exemple non mais pour
la cour du roi ou à versailles
non ce qui est marrant c'est que
justement voilà on a des personnes qui
sont royalistes qui adore le morceau
d'autres qui sont pas du tout réaliste
qu'il aime doute qu'ils s'envoyaient des
personnes qui sont royalistes il ya à la
fois des personnes qui sont royalistes
et guillem et d'autres qui perce
quelle équipe qui pensent qu'on veut on
se fout des royalistes d'accord il ya
202 clash forcément vous l'avez tout à
l'heure les premiers slameur qui
viennent pas de la cour pénale mais de
la cour royale plus tôt c'est ce que
vous y êtes vous avez une admiration
pour ces textes aussi où ça aussi c'est
juste pour la blague ou ce sera racine
molière
oui bien sûr enfin je veux dire on a
fait ça fait partie de notre culture on
a agrandi à versailles et voilà c'est
quelque chose
oui c'est sûr c'est dans les
commentaires on a eu des commentaires et
ses biens durables élevé aux aubes et
israël ou les choses comme ça je pense
qu'on ouais c'est vrai qu'on fait ça
tient de la blague on fait un truc
décalé maintenant on a essayé de faire
ça proprement au niveau du texte c'est
un travail dessus et je pense que c'est
ça qui est bien travaillé sur le clip
aussi parce qu'on vient d'en voir un
extrait de ce clip qui ont tous fait
quatre minutes 60000 vu sur internet et
ce qui est plutôt apprécié aussi c'est
la réalisation vous avez eu les moyens
de son tournage du clip maintenant en
fait il a été réalisé avec très peu de
moyens mais c'est justement une équipe
soudée qui croyaient au projet qu'il l'a
fait et justement on se dit voilà si on
a si vous avez un projet s'il ya quelque
chose qui vous plaît réussi ni c'est une
bande de potes
prenez une caméra alesi lancez vous
parce que ben voilà avec avec du coeur
ça peut ça peut le faire si vous êtes
sincère et puis voilà ça marche et la
trois cols rendu est bluffant sur la
qualité pour la quête d'une qualité du
clip effectivement quand vous avez
tourné à versailles ça a été perçu comme
on tourne on n'a pas tourné avait
réclamé par le masque lundi un lundi on
était à versailles mais c'est vrai on
n'a pas tourné à verser à versailles ah
je sais pas peut-être qu'on n'aurait pas
eu les droits sur le château non mais en
tout cas en tout cas faut revoir on est
allé à versailles lundi
et d'ailleurs ce qui était drôle c'est
qu'on est arrivé lundi on l'a publié le
vendredi et déjà des personnes qui
l'avait vu sur place donc c'était drôle
d'être confronté à ça mais ça a été
plutôt donc bien perçu chez il ya
d'autres morceaux qui vont sortir
vous allez rester définitivement comme
ça c'est très dur cette interview quand
j'observe c'est difficile de rester
sérieux et il ya d'autres morceaux va
changer de thème je pense qu'on va
changer de thème complètement le premier
le prochain morceau parlera de la
promiscuité au kazakhstan et voix de
thèmes engagés comme ça
oui bien sûr non mais effectivement on a
d'autres choses de prévues enfin je veux
dire on a été sollicité que ce soit en
donnant notre tournée au vatican brésil
on a d'ailleurs eu un grand grand succès
il les faut savoir que là bas les
footballeurs ont abandonné les
chaussettes rayées pour reprendre les
mi-bas le serre-tête revient à la mode
enfin je crois que ç'a vraiment un grand
impact donc on va continuer encore un
album complet oui à suivre forcément on
aura l'occasion d'en reparler
vous disiez vous êtes musicien la base
c'est bon moi j'ai créé en tout cas
depuis depuis longtemps mon frère fait
plus était plus dans le cinéma scénario
est tout et c est moi ça fait quelques
années que j'écris les morceaux donc on
a des choses à dire
vous travaillez encore à côté vous allez
vous consacrer pleinement pleinement au
groupe
maintenant je pense qu'on va faire un
tour non en fait c'est voilà c'est ça
fait partie de notre vie c'est une
diversité ça nous plaît pour l'instant
ça marche on est à dix mille vues par
jour voilà s'appelait et effectivement
on a envie de continuer dans cette veine
là mais voilà comme on fait plein de
choses et c'est ça qui est bien quoi et
prochainement en concert à versailles
oui entre deux spectacles équestres au
château offre bartabas exactement oxmo
puccino m citron vert donc qu'ils
étaient allés tous sur le plateau une
petite dernière série de questions des
rappeurs français vous me dites juste si
vous êtes fan ou pas fan
mc solaar oxmo puccino kery james
kery james whale à sa personnalité c'est
pas là la fouine
- moi c'est moi moi ça revienne un peu
plus loin alors ntm ntm va bien sûr on y
rend hommage dans le montrer a
celebration oui vive la police et iam
iam iam
on a été intense et l'école alors
vraiment j'ai été élevé à l'aide du
micro d'argent moi il ya des choses
modernes maintenant des choses
contemporaines au niveau durable qui se
fait qu'ils sont qui est supérieur de 9
1 et 9 9,5
orelsan c'est des choses qu'on écoute en
tout cas c'est super au niveau de
l'écriture on n'est pas toujours
d'accord avec les messages on a
peut-être vous serez sur scène avec eux
prochainement avec soul hip hop de
versailles merci à tous les deux hugo et
mathias savary alias m citron vert et
oxmo puccino hip hop de versailles l'un
des buzz de ce moment
et c'est la fin de cette édition je vous
retrouve lundi en direct 18h excellent
week end